I personally I personally think that the
problem these days in modern culture
whatever you want to call it is that
people is actually focusing on the wrong
things so these girls are talking about
and I think there was recently these
guys who came in and said they were high
value men and they wear flashy stuff
they act you know a certain way and I
can tell you that a high value woman the
ones that you actually the good ones
that you want as a wife they're not
going to say yes to that guy because
they're gonna see him and be like oh
he's so insecure he needs to drive a
Lambo in order to feel slightly slightly
better about himself slightly because
guess what under all those cologne nice
shirts whatever Gucci belts whatever you
want to call it
it's a very insecure person who needs
that physical reassurement